bismillah al hamdulillah assalamualaikum
greetings of peace I was asked a very
important question what do you have to
say about the countless the many
terrorist attacks that are being
committed in the name of Islam well I
want to try to touch upon this in a few
different aspects one is we absolutely
one hundred percent categorically
condemn any and all terrorist attacks
that are done in the name of Islam this
is something that's very clear and
Muslims speak out against this the
mainstream organizations in America and
all over the globe have come out and
condemned such acts so this is very
clear now not only do we condemn any
killing of innocent life not just one
but all and now because certain events
are being highlighted we shouldn't
forget about many of the other terrorist
attacks that are happening daily in our
own backyards you know people are being
decapitated you have have you ever heard
of the Colombian necktie this is where
the throat is being slit you have
terrorist gang bangers in our own
backyards who are terrorizing people and
these crimes are committed daily and
many of them because they don't suit the
agenda you don't see the news media
really covering these things but now
there we have to admit there there are
opponents there the Islamophobia machine
is a over 200 million dollar a year
industry is big business bashing Islam
now I want to take also some
accountability we asked we have to also
want from one aspect let me start off
with that we're going to say that Islam
you get a one-way ticket the understand
this anyone who is practicing submission
to the will of the Creator the
all-loving the all-merciful God the same
God of Jesus Moses Abraham and the last
and final message of problem Hamid peace
and blessings be upon them all
if you kill an innocent human being you
land yourself a one-way ticket to the
Hellfire and if you were in such a thing
there's no such thing that's another
very important aspect as the Islamic
state imagine right now as the Christian
KKK somewhere in Alabama got together
and said look we're starting the
Christians state how ridiculous would
that sound that's how ridiculous it
sounded we shouldn't just you know these
new terms are being developed daily and
we just bite on them there's no such
thing as an Islamic state you have the
Una's la McStay doing Una's llama things
isis daesh the anti-islamic state they
do everything anti-islam this is very
clear because as the Creator is saying
in the verbatim word of God and chapter
5 killing one innocent human being as is
as if you kill the entire humanity how
do you like that what I mean this is so
deep in for profound you don't find this
anywhere mention in any other scripture
in any Constitution in the world saving
one innocent life is as if you save the
world and we don't need some radical
hate preacher to tell us opposite of
what this verse means it's very clear
and the consensus of Islamic
scholarships is also clear on this and
it's very important that you see that
now you've had these radical politicians
hate mongers hate preachers it's so easy
to divide humanity instead of bringing
humanity together you have people
dividing us and instead of giving the
platform to those who are promoting
peace you are giving platform to people
who are promoting disharmony disunity
creating fear and now you have groups
being made and that's what's happening
today if you really care that these
mainstream media organizations really
cared and they really you know the
Creator tells us in the Quran in the
second chapter that there's though
who say that they want peace but
actually those are the ones who are the
peace breakers the ones who are
promoting the opposite of peace and
that's what you see you see that if you
if people really if these Fox News and
many of these other mainstream
organizations if they really wanted to
solve these problems what would happen
why don't you bring on the majority the
ninety-nine percent point nine percent
of peaceful Muslims out there who
condemn these acts of terrorism who
condemn senseless violence no instead
they bring out these radical
Islamophobes xenophobes they bring on
these people who have the same
interpretation of Islam as the daesh as
the anti-islamic stay the same as these
radicals out there and no wonder then
groups are being formally this thug gang
like mentality is being made so that's
one so we covered one aspect Islam is
very clear on this you have a one-way
ticket did you die mean very clear
one-way ticket to the Hellfire if you
take an innocent life going into a you
know have these this guy I you know a
Muslims heart pounds you know a breaks
in sorrow and in pain you know because
you know how Islam gets put on the
witness stand Muslims have the most to
lose what do does Islam or Muslims have
to gain by this nothing but when you
have for instance let's take for example
these recent terrorist attacks and you
look at it objectively you see that this
individual who drove this truck this was
in recently in France the first victim
by the way was a Muslim grandmother and
again one innocent life is tragic enough
but the multitude that was senselessly
killed by what by a person who was sick
and deranged some sociopath someone who
was
because um pnt bulky mazda why he
disappeared as a Penelope to serve the
country we need to 47 below in viola
plays condom on which he made a hash
efficient ship will volley did you do
you've already been looking upon their
second to also some people suck ya na ba
hafiz a cemetery he is believed to be
the first killed in the atrocity the
first person believed to have died in a
nice terror attack was a Muslim woman
everything that Islam says not to do he
was doing it so we should really be
looking for people who are out
practicing you know who are fornicating
who are out in the night clubs or I mean
if you want to go by that logic these
are the people that should be
surveillance because if this this this
this psychopath this sick and deranged
evil individual if he was following
Islam he wouldn't have done any of these
actions same thing with the person in
Florida he was during Ramadan if he was
with his family doing so for if he was
breaking starting his day with the fast
if he wouldn't have been in in any
illicit relationship you would have had
a family he would have been a peaceful
person praying to God seeking guidance
and peas totally away from any nightclub
and any of these these these things that
Islam calls people away from but you see
countless times anyone who has anything
to do with these despicable despise
about acts his life testifies this he's
doing everything opposite to it to Islam
so we got that out of the way I want to
make this kind of short I don't want to
go on too long but one Islam condemns it
Muslims condemn it has nothing to do is
this not Isis exists because the United
States invaded Iraq and destroyed all
the institutions that country and left
it a complete mess that's that's a fact
okay Isis doesn't exist because of Islam
because Islam was in Iraq before 2003
and there was no Sunni extremists there
was no Sonny terrorism there was no ages
before 2003 this result this emerged in
Iraq at because of the United States
invasion
that's what caused Isis Islam didn't
cause Isis but if you look at the US
media it's obsessed with getting people
to talk about Islam the cause of Isis
Isis because of Islam why does it do
that because the function of media and
government is to prevent people from
actually in this case prevent them from
actually reflecting on the actual causes
of this phenomenon which is the United
States unjust war mongering because if
people SAT there and said hey wait a
second we got talked into invading this
country it was a total disaster now we
have this Isis business then they might
say maybe we shouldn't go and invade
countries the next time we're asked by
our government to support a war that's
not what the kind of power elites or the
military media industrial complex once
they want people thinking like that so
they have to sit and place the focus on
some other cause it was cuz of Islam
they don't want Americans actually
thinking about really cause this thing
so when I when I what I tell you you
know Muslims or even non-muslims about
this is don't be bamboozled by what you
see on TV is very simple I mean I know
it's obvious but just because people say
stuff a lot on TV doesn't make it true
the so-called ation these people who are
given the platform better yet instead of
promoting them because if you were
promoting KKK and these militia these
terrorists that are many of them who are
out there today who are the bigger
threat you would see that they would win
recruits you would be actually promote
helping to promote them and that's
what's happening so now when you have
these radical hate preachers who are
given the microphone these politicians
and the so-called experts of Islam what
happens now you have people it's either
you're with us or with them you have
announcement I'm going to come to the
point of Muslims taking accountability
because what happens is the Muslims are
getting educated by these radical hate
preachers on TV and i'm not i'm not time
talking about the the people on the fox
news and these people who are who are
promoting this division amongst humanity
and now they think okay it's that thug
like gang mentality they're like oh this
must be the guys not sitting with a
scholar in islam if he was sitting you
know at a madrassa or he was sitting at
islamic university it will be teaching
him that he could
do this what happens he doesn't open up
the car I he doesn't go sit with a
teacher someone of knowledge who's who's
talking about having the best manners
the best etiquettes being a vest noble
character and all the things that Islam
preaches and teaches you know the
problem Hamid peace and blessings be
upon him he said I have not been sent
except to perfect good manners is that
good manners I mean doing all of these
things that are opposite to Islam you
know the first thing that a person a
Muslim will be accountable for you know
if he had innocent blood on his hands I
mean what what what what a human being
who wants to get to paradise is going to
come to in front of God with innocent
blood on inside this is ludicrous is
crazy but what happens the Quran in the
Muslims life has been put on the shelf
and when someone dies they blow the dust
off and they read it may be just as a
ritual and there it isn't they're not
connected to it and then they see all of
these things that are going on in the
media and now they say ok now I gotta
join what's up is obviously what what
they're teaching must be aslam so now i
gotta pick i gotta be again back to that
gang thug like mentality so now they end
up picking site now they end up because
they're already being discriminated are
already being being ostracized and
because the guy's name is muhammad and
now he's he's so what he ends up joining
now he's he ends up doing something
Despicable into something evil because
he's radicalized by who by that hate
preachers the Fox like experts of Islam
who are educating him instead of giving
the platform to those peaceful
law-abiding citizens who are out there
promoting peace and understanding giving
them the platform to call if you wanted
to end this put the Muslims understand
put the Muslims who are out there
promoting what Islam truly is about
instead of some so-called experts let
them have the microphone on Fox News the
platform to call these lost souls people
who have who have lost themselves or as
Apple's as American Pie who are just
consumed with the culture and now you
know with all the other traumas that are
happening in people's lives
who are lost and somehow they end up
doing something that is totally wrong is
totally is something evil and that's
going to be one solution to the problem
that's going to be a means in a way to
help put an end to this so that's one
thing another thing we have to
understand is is that along with Muslims
many of them being very uneducated very
far away from Islam and manipulated by
by the media and maybe even and some
some some extreme elements out there we
need to get educated on what Islam is
really about and not from Fox News and
not from the media you have to really
start to live Islam because when you get
to know Islam you live Islam you see the
love that it promotes the understanding
that approach that justice that it
promotes and the peace that it calls one
to a piece that you have with your
Creator then you have that peace within
yourself in society around you and then
you live this way of life that you you
would dread you you would be having such
a ill feeling in your heart to want to
bring harm to even an animal let alone a
human being that's one thing the other
thing is that we also have to understand
that there are a lot of things that are
cooked up nowadays fixed up as one might
say you know you have people who aren't
bought people who aren't also going
along with a certain agenda who come out
and tell us these things that many of
many of the the events that are
happening you know out in the world we
have to also be weary that there is an
agenda being pushed it was done in the
past and fear it's being done in the
present and fear is is a weapon that's
being used we have to as intelligent
human beings we cannot be people who
will be easily manipulated just like
sheep being led to the slaughter we have
to you
the faculties that the almighty has
given us and you have to ask questions
and make that human connection so for
the not yet Muslims for the for the
people who are out there for the
non-muslims you know don't fall victim I
say to this propaganda to this height
that's out there that's dividing us we
are one human race you should get to
know your Muslim neighbor asked
questions we have a 1-800 number 1 866
to Islam 4752 at the end ask your
questions eliminate these fears and you
will see that Muslims you know there's
so many examples that when people are
writing you know in UK it brings to mind
the Muslims were guarding the non-muslim
businesses Muslims will be the first to
come up and to defend you because
Muslims are some of the most God
conscious people with Muslims who are
living Islamic Muslim is one who simply
submit submits his will to the will of
the creator he's not talk about harming
you he's not trying to bring havoc to
the earth he's trying to make peace in
his life and on earth so this is one of
the greatest delusions that is being
perpetuated out there is dividing us and
another thing i want to tell muslims now
this is a golden opportunity to share to
do Dawa and some basic things that we
can do one of the most important things
is to open up the muskets I you know for
the community leaders that are out there
one of the most effective tools are open
houses for 23 mile radius around every
mustard you should have people going out
and giving out information pamphlets
about Islam dispelling these myths and
inviting people to come into the mosque
the mustards to learn to have open
houses to dispel to alleviate many of
these fears people have fallen victim to
this to the Islamophobia machine and
much of this hate rhetoric and what are
you going to do you're going to sit and
have your head in the dirt in the
and as they say and not take this
opportunity serious because you might
not have an opportunity next year as
laws get changed more fear is
perpetuated laws get changed and now you
can't even share this Dean that helps to
bring purpose to people's lives to help
spread peace so that's one of the key
things that we need to do we really need
to get out and educate humanity make the
human connection that's one of the
greatest weight is in the musters
inviting people having these open houses
to three-mile radius out there giving
people to information about Islam
passing out leaflets and and flyers and
inviting people your neighbors who to
the left of you to the right of you
reaching out to them inviting them to
ask questions and not being ignorant
knowing how to dispel also educating
yourself on having good talking points
that you can go ahead and when someone
brings up something that you're not just
like someone who is is struck and lost
when something is asked to you about
your religion about your Dean and then
when you also know it you're going to be
more convinced of it you're going to
practice it more you're going to be far
away from hurting like I say an animal
let alone an animal let alone even a
human being because again that's a
Muslims one-way ticket to the hell fire
killing any human soul and this is this
is just my thoughts I wanted to share
with you look into Islam don't be scared
of Islam it's a way of life that was
lived by Abraham by Moses by Jesus peace
be upon him by his Blessed Mother that
there's a whole chapter named after
Jesus's mother in the Quran and when you
see your Muslim you don't fear those
nuns who are wearing hijab do you I
often challenged people to tell me the
color of Mary the mother of Jesus is
here we see our sisters nowadays they go
into places and they feel like all eyes
are on them because they represent Islam
on the outside people see them with the
hijab and there they feel this tension
in the air so next time you see a Muslim
woman you
don't fear the none do you who's
imitating who's trying to to be one who
dedicated her life to god this is the
same thing that a Muslim woman has does
she's imitating the mother of Jesus
peace be upon her and him that no Muslim
is a Muslim unless we cannot be the
Antichrist these are some of the things
that we as most we don't understand this
is what people are thinking I think
Muslims are the Antichrist they think
they had all sorts of crazy and
ridiculous things that simple talking
points that you know can dispel these
myths and these misconceptions the next
time you see a Muslim woman don't be
scared of her be open and be wise enough
know that this woman has dedicated her
life to pleasing God she's not trying to
harm you or anyone in humanity ask a
Muslim that you see a Muslim what he
believes what he thinks start a
conversation make the human connection
we got this one 800-number there for
anybody who has some questions some fear
some apprehension looms be courageous
enough to call us 1 866 to Islam and
then why don't you pick up the Quran
read it see what it says in context
those that's your homework meet a Muslim
talk to a Muslim going to a mosque read
the Quran call this 1 800 number and for
the Muslims get to know your Islam don't
just pick it up off the shelf when
someone dies as a ritual blow the dust
off it get to know your religion and
give the platform to those who advocate
for peace the ninety-nine point nine
percent of Muslims living in America
give them the platform if you really
want peace let them call those lost
souls who might have been radicalized
let them call them back to Islam if you
really want that don't invite the
so-called experts who have more in
common with the Una's la mcstay and then
you're wondering why people are getting
radicalized picking sides joining like a
gang that gang thug like mentality we're
here to help we're here to spread that
message of peace by sharing and
educating and then in short I try to
make it concise I hope some of the
apprehensions that you might have had
alleviate it continue to watch the Dean
show to learn more call us and we start
with peace my brothers and sisters and
that's what we look to have with our
Creator first and foremost the One God
the same God of Jesus you can't be a
Muslim unless you loved and revered
Jesus is one of the mightiest messages
God Almighty has sent I always say it
that should be a unifier to bring us
together and he greeted his followers
with peace and we end we started with it
and we wish peace upon you and peace for
all of humanity and let's be people will
advocate peace not just by lip service
but by action we'll see you next time
until then Salaam alaikum peace be with
you